will we ever actually get a conclusion
to stargate universe
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so when i'm talking about stargate i get
a lot of messages basically saying if
they don't give me an answer to stargate
universe i ain't watching this show or
will they ever give us an answer to
stargate universe
[Music]
[Music]
well i can actually tell you that brad
wright does seem to want to give us a
conclusion to that story
joseph malozzi has recently responded to
a tweet basically asking him directly
will we get an answer to the sgu saga
and he said yes
we also know from companion and some of
brad wright's conversations that he does
fully intend giving us an answer to the
sgu
and we'll actually find out what
happened to eli and the rest of the crew
this is one of the many corridors aboard
the destiny this one leads to the
communication lab i think
we're still finding our way around but
fortunately for you i have a pretty good
sense of direction
not the com lab so if you are a regular
site tracker you'll know that i actually
do have contacts that work in and around
mgm so i go to one of them and i ask
them directly what is the word around
the offices do you think we'll ever
actually get a response to the sgu
problem
well he actually was a very firm
believer in that we will he said that
there are a lot of questions left
unanswered by what was always a very
ambitious tv show
the whole reason for the destiny's
existence was to answer the biggest
questions that even the ancients did ask
they found a secret code embedded in the
background radiation of the universe a
secret code that may have existed for as
long as time and space had existed and
they wanted to go as close to the center
of the universe to get a clearest
ability to see that signal as possible
that was the whole reason for the
destiny's mission she'll want to post
mortom on his latest fiasco but what
she's really interested in is russia's
little signal from god i never called it
that
well
that's what a lot of them are calling me
back home and can you really think of a
much bigger question to try to ask
now it would seem that the ancients
abandoned that project
i imagine ascending will have helped
them answer the question a bit quicker
than a spaceship flying even at fdl
through the galaxy so i suppose the
question became redundant once they
became all mighty powerful beings
gods themselves you could argue
but
we didn't get to see the answer and as
far as we know those crew are still
flying through the galaxy in stasis eli
is still desperately trying to fix the
ship and solve the power problem
we do have some comic books that gave us
some interest in beta cannon about what
may be happened aboard the sgu after the
series ended but that is always just
beta cannon until we see it on the
screen
i would argue it didn't really happen
but i do love the way the comics went
and if you've not seen them um basically
eli kind of half fixed the power problem
but then was suddenly surrounded by a
bunch of other people they actually
turned out to be some of the ancient
engineers engineers that had constructed
the destiny over a million years
previously that had been in stasis
somewhere else aboard the ship that
they'd not found yet and they'd been
woken up
the storyline went on i won't spoil it
but there was never actually a proper
conclusion even in beta cannon
i just love the way they did take the
story and i kind of hope that's how
series three would have gone with their
stargate universe because i think it was
a really clever plotline
so what did my friend mgm have to say
well they are convinced actually that
when mgm does restart stargate and that
will be really really soon we're talking
months not years that they will have 10
or 12 episode runs so that is the norm
now for streaming services and he's
absolutely certain that's how they will
go about it
he thinks they will try to do sort of
like what star wars has done with the
book of boba fett in the mandalorian
series and sort of have two or three
series maybe running um alongside each
other through the year
kind of in the same way star wars has
but those stargaze series except maybe
for a prequel series even though that to
a point as well and basically what
happens in one will influence the others
eli wallace
actually uh
eli's not here right now
okay
okay okay whatever you guys think that i
did i swear you got the wrong guy do i
look like someone who'd be standing here
if i didn't already know everything
there is to know about you
yeah not really
right so how could resolving stargate
universe come into that
well one of those 10 or 12 episode
series
that will probably be focused around
certain storylines each series could
focus on the sgu they could focus on for
some reason having to go out and rescue
the crew or for some reason having to go
to the destiny i i don't think it would
just be a straight rescue mission i
suspect that there would be some sort of
bigger problem that going to the destiny
can resolve
i'm really thinking that something will
happen or something will be needed for
them to go to the destiny just rescuing
the crew probably won't be an
interesting enough story
the other way they could do it is if it
was a longer series they could just do a
double episode for example where
actually rescuing the crew is the point
and it's incredibly dangerous
but
just a double episode nothing a great
deal more than that
my pal at mgm though suggests that
that's probably not the way they would
go and that it would become integral to
the larger plot story so how can i see
this going
i think the first series of stargate
when it returns
initially at very least will have to be
very much about laying the foundation 15
years has passed since star gate one
ended a lot has happened in those years
when stargate has been off our screens
they're gonna have to get us up to speed
at that point as well they're gonna have
to explain where the stargate atlantis
is and what happened with that after
they just left in san francisco bay
we're gonna have to find out where the
stargate project is now if it is this
opens thing that everybody knows about
it where are we with the lucian alliance
and blah blah blah blah blah they're
also going to have to establish a new
villain all of this is going to take a
little bit of time and i think probably
will fill up the entire first series or
first 10 or 12 episodes or whatever we
end up seeing
but following that i am convinced we
will actually get a response to the sgu
conundrum
what happened to eli and all his friends
and can we get them home
so get into the comments guys is this
something you're desperately wanting to
see if we do finally get stargate back
on our screens and how important is it
really if they never actually go back to
the destiny does it really matter in the
great scheme of things if the tv show is
on our screens so if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification it really helps us out
and you can become a fully fledged
sidetracker and support the channel
please consider hitting the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you